bonsoir à tous bonsoir je vous laisse à
arriver au fur et à mesure on est parti
pour une nouvelle session ensemble
alors je fais en même temps les petits
et les petites fuites vous êtes au
courant je vous laisse vous installer au
fur et à mesure
or aujourd'hui on va essayer de faire ça
correctement le
le petit et le petit robot le petit
bottes
alors est ce que ça marche c'est ce que
ça fonctionne
hop là je vais vous laisser vous
installer à faire la mesure dite
monolithique quand vous êtes là
n'hésitez pas à me donner des nouvelles
de passer un bon réveillon
et puis moi je fais comme d'habitude
les petits et petits réglages
si vous m'entendez aussi bien sûr
si je fais ça parce que ça fonctionne
oui c'est beau
bonsoir à tous
je trouve comme vous voyez la chantera
de devoir sinon le petit bottes il
fonctionne n'hésitez pas à l'essayer
aussi ça me permettra de voir si vous
arrivez
à l'utiliser
pour regarder si je fais ça
alors le premier n'a pas fonctionné
pendant referais ça vite fait
alors comme vous l'avez vu dans le titre
du twitter je pense que ce que vous avez
vu de suite passé on va ce soir on va
parler d'eux
le joueur de michigan state je peux
titre au basket ce soir à wade à qui va
jouer ce soir bon bah écoute j'espère
qu'il va faire du salsa c'est que c'est
un des joueurs préférés
de la draft ya deux ans un jeune que
j'aime beaucoup donc
donc on va éviter que le meilleur moi
j'ai appris que l'on nous on l'était
cogiter là donc
c'est un peu triste inside mais ça va
aller ça va le faire donc quoi comme je
disais ce soir on va parler de michigan
state deux jours de michigan state en
deux trois jours du michigan s'est élevé
max christie qui est un prospect 5
étoiles très coté gaye one qui est un
seigneur nous quatrième année en ailier
soulier ledit douvres est peut-être pu
lire quelque chose dans le dernier
article d'alexandre avait pas de stat
avancé de l'ailier un petit peu qu'on
peut trouver au second tour facilement
et enfin marcus bingham qui junior qui
est un pivot seniors aussi donc voilà
deux mecs expérimenté un freshman et
puis on verra comme d'habitude
faire les profils avec les mensurations
les stars et les stats à bronzer et puis
surtout du clip je vous ai préparé pas
mal de clips pour ce soir comme
d'habitude elle
ment ça c'est bon tiens un look cité
dans le chat et c'est habituel et ça ne
dérange pas les commandes
tapez par exemple tu vois les ce que
j'ai essayé la les points d'exclamation
twitter pour voir si ça marche ou pas
ou si c'est que sur moi que ça
fonctionne et que là on a j'ai encore
fait encore des réglages qui fonctionne
pas
je vais modifier ça aussi
pour que les gens qui arrivent suivra
dans le titre
à ce point d'exclamation l'occident ça
fonctionne pas
et points
y'est c'est bon je suis pas trop mauvais
la vieille personne ne s'en est pas trop
mal sorti merci l'axé c'est gentil donc
voilà comme je le disais trois jours de
michigan state et puis après on peut
peut-être se sait se faire un petit jeu
ensemble pour pouvoir voir à quelle
heure calories sera et puis voir final
l'aspiration ou pas on va pas tarder
21h03 tranquillement se mettre sur le
site
envergure up ici regardez ce qui est un
peu sorti pour aller la période de fêtes
si je vous fais ça je vous fais ça
normalement
vous avez le site qui s'affiche toujours
avec la connexion de la campagne il faut
être tolérant
alors qu'est ce que ça dit
on commence pas le pivot ouais je pense
qu'on va commencer par le pivot
been can juniors après on parlera pas ce
qu'on va être on va le faire du moins
côté au plus côté donc bingham junior
ensuite on fera
pwan et enfin offre
max christie ex christie qui n'a rien à
avoir avec
tout christian le joueur nba
tout neuf là si vous arrivez sur
envergure que vous n'êtes pas venu
pendant les fêtes aucun problème on a un
article sur yoann mcqueen doux qui est
un joueur qui joue à auch où lé basket
ball en france qui commence vraiment à
devenir intéressant pour les pour les
scouts vous avez un article qui parle
des pépites allèles que je vous regarde
pas ce que dedans il ya un joueur qui
nous intéresse on va pas aller
aujourd'hui et puis sur le côté les
scouting report dont aujourd'hui justin
moore justin mans l'ailier que vous avez
pu suivre avec moi
quand on a fait le stream shirley on a
fait le stream sur les prospects de
villanova on avait vu justin moore parmi
les quatre rappels nour samuel philippe
6 etf layton et donc voilà ça scouting
report que j'ai écrit
si vous étiez là quand on a fait ce
stream bon ben vous savez déjà peu près
tout et puis bah sinon vous avez le
scouting report que vous pouvez ouvrir
ici entre autres
quand çà voudra bien fonctionné c'est
pas très grave avec comme d'habitude les
stats le profil physique et puis au
niveau du scouting report les qualités
et les défauts du joueur voilà avec on
comprend ce qui est intéressant
dans cet article là on te laisse de côté
aujourd'hui on a dit ce qui nous
intéresse nous
c'est des joueurs de michigan state donc
on va commencer par mark bingham
marc duhem ça s'ouvre ici peut-être que
c'est un jour que vous ne connaissez pas
ça fait quatre ans qui fait ça
ça fait quatre ans qu'ils roulent un peu
sa bosse en en 6è du côté de michigan
state excusez moi je dis juste aux
copains qu'on est en live
pardon ouais ça fait quatre ans qui
roule sa bosse du coup d'oeil michigan
state nous qui les catégoriser en forme
mais sert un pivot grandi dans la région
là vous l'avez ici à deux centimètres
102 kg il a été actualisée sur plusieurs
sites à 213 cm 104 kg ça c'est plus cela
le poids qu'il avait flatté qu'ils
avaient quand il est arrivé à la fac
quatre ans et ça c'est le poids de début
d'année pourquoi je vous parle du poids
c'est parce que c'est un joueur quand il
arrivait en une cité il faisait à peine
90 kg donc très fin et c'est pour ça
comme vous allez pouvoir le voir qu'en
première année joue pas 3 5 minutes que
l'an dernier enfin il ya trois ans ils
jouent aux minutes donc faire moins de
deux ans onze minutes l'an dernier aux
mines externe et enfin il explose 22
minutes tout simplement parce qu'il a
pris dix kilos et qui peut rester sur le
terrain voilà donc ça se voit au niveau
des points ensuite et enfin des stades
ou général forcément quand on double
tonton du jeu on passe de 3 5 points 11
points vous allez sûrement temps de
denia où c'est mon grand qui vient nous
rejoindre pour connais mes grands chats
donc voilà 3,5 points à 11 points on a
ça ne m'intéresse pas au niveau des
rebonds on est à 8 rebonds total donc à
peu près deux tiers de défensif 6
rebonds et 1,6 et 2,3 en offensif on est
moins d'une passe par match on est à une
style pas un match ça m'intéresse
donc l'arrivée à intercepter un ballon
pour un intérieur trois blocks par match
donc ça fait je crois qu'ils les
premiers ou deuxièmes en big ten pickton
c'est une conférence donc
à face est unanime et dort donc une des
six plus grosses conférences est signée
michigan state est un des programmes les
plus connus de cette conférence vu que
il a accueilli entre autres le grand
l'unique magic johnson dans les années
80 60 80 pardon et puis plus récemment
de michigan state on à mike the witches
on a déjà regagné axones junior on a des
nouvelles valentine's on à kariya rice
et j'en passe forcément xavier thilleman
qui joue aussi du côté de memphis voilà
donc une une équipe qui est coachée par
tom izzo qui est un des plus grands
comptes universitaire et donc voilà
si cette année est une des places fortes
ont été élevés note est forcément je
n'étais là j'étais péril les avocats de
chicago pendant longtemps c'est un des
joueurs qui m'a fait aimer le basket
universitaire et très bonne green
évidemment qui est peut-être le meilleur
joueur issu de michigan state
actuellement en activité dans cette
conférence vous avez aussi michigan vous
avez enough vous avez à ohio state vous
avez penn state farm d'ailleurs plein de
très très gros programme
iowa entre autres pure audio avec
tedenby donc plein de gros programmes
majeurs
donc on a vu 22 minutes par match
partageur 40 y partager le temps de jeu
teinte sur le poste de pivot avec deuce
marble est toujours des rotations assez
courtes peines et quand les temps de jeu
assez petit quand je porte à misau ses
faux-pas faut pas s'étonner de sa
4 fautes donc c'est un joueur qui arrive
à rester sur le terrain et puis
maintenant qu'on a vu ça on va pouvoir
regarder un peu les stades avancés
c'est pour le profil un peu global
termes de pourcentage vous connaissez
maintenant j'utilise deux sites
principalement alors normalement les
stats de base vous les avez un sur notre
site internet mais là j'ai vu que le
lien lurel avait pas été bien rentrés
dans le dans la fiche du site dans la
partie modération nous que marc feret je
demanderai à maxime qui gère la
conférence de la refaire mais ce sera
actualisé normalement toutes ses stats
là de basket-ball returns vous avez
directement sur notre site d'envergure
marcus bingham
junior toujours important de l'ingénieur
c'est un joueur qui est le troisième
plus gros volume de tir de l'équipe
c'est ce que vous voyez ici mat pour
ceux qui connaissent pas le site qui
n'ont pas l'habitude nos stream c'est un
site qui vous donne la répartition des
tirs d'un joueur vous avez les tirs près
du panier sur cette colonne là vous avez
les deux points en fait intermédiaire
sur cette colonne là et vous avez ici
les trois points sur cette colonne ici
ça c'est la répartition terme de telles
statistiques ensuite vous avez
l'efficacité dans ce dans ce secteur
toujours juste à côté donc ici et
ensuite ici eux ici pardon
et enfin vous avez le ratio en fait
entre les tireurs issus d'une passe
décisive et les tiers qui sont pris sans
pas d'ici créé par le joueur donc par
exemple si on regarde par l'ats markus
bingham juniors vous avez un joueur qui
va prendre sa composante ces tirs près
du cercle qui va être efficace à 82 % ce
qui est très très bon et 70% des tirs
qu'il prend près du panier sont ici une
passe décisive donc c'est vraiment un
joueur classique l'intérieur classique
qui va dépendre de son gameplay son
honneur de son porteur de balle pour se
créer un accès au panier et finir en
fait souvent près du panier en dunk
après une passe décisif ça c'est la
moitié de ces tirs l'autre moitié de ces
tiers vous l'avez appris à mi distance
vous avez une
42% s'est surpris à mi distance pour 38%
de réussite sur les deux points long ça
ça m'intéresse aux six un joueur qui a
de plus en plus écartée son jeu au fur
et à mesure des années et encore une
fois 71% issue d'une passe décisive donc
là encore vous êtes sur une situation de
pick and roll je re le panier je
m'arrête à mi distance parce que la
défense et foot us près du cercle et je
peux avec un pool up avec un club avec
un tir sanctionner la défense et enfin
de façon très anecdotique 8% de tirs à
trois points donc ça représente un tir à
trois points par match à peine plus tôt
0,6 tirs à trois points par match si
vous entendez du bruit derrière c'est
parce que j'ai ma famille qui forcément
est activé ce qu'ils aient mois 8 % de
tirs à trois points de wallace et moins
d'un tiers de romane très anecdotique
pour une réussite à moins de 30% ce qui
m'a intéressé qu'ils en prennent de plus
en plus on est à 12 sur l'année donc
voila tout petit échantillon
et c'est très peu représentatif d'un
congrès le pourcentage ça m'intéresse
pas vraiment
un indicateur de tiers ça peut être la
réussite aux lancers-francs 75 % ce qui
est correct sans être exceptionnel
et enfin stats que je prends aussi
ici c'est le nombre de lancers francs
tentés par rapport au nombre de tirs
tentés alors moi je la mets toujours en
relation non vous avez l'habitude avec
le nombre de tirs pris près du panier
donc ici vous avez un joueur qui prend
la moitié de cette serre près du panier
nos environ
comment dire environ une fois sur deux
lorsqu'il va au cercle il va trouver un
lancer-franc ont peut-être l'avoir ici
en corrélation si je vous dis pas de
bêtises on a vu la moitié des deux tiers
prêts pris près du panier donc ça veut
dire que vous avez trois quatre tirs
pris près du panier et vous avez 2,7
lancers francs voilà c'est à peu près
comme ça qu'on peut l'interpréter une
fois sur deux lorsque je vais au ca que
je tire un lancer-franc
deuxième site hyper intéressant pour les
as tu avances et wind à elle bienvenue
parmi nous et cette avancée c'est
intéressant qu'on les comprend en fait
ouais je suis d'acord c'est pas
forcément évident de se mettre dedans
c'est faire beaucoup de chiffres et des
stats façon comme tout on peut leur
faire dire n'importe quoi donc ce qui
est toujours intéressant c'est d'avoir
un contexte de les mettre en relation
avec un volume de les mettre en relation
avec autre chose voilà deux il faut pas
sortir une scène comme ça faut plutôt
faire un bilan statistique et essayer de
mettre des liens et c'est pour ça que
j'aime bien le deuxième site qui est là
qui s'appelle explorer vous l'avez ici
tout tout tout
ouais je vais essayer de me mettre des
liens au fur et à mesure cette fois ci
j'avais prévu un peu de côté hop
j'arrive à m'en excuser moi up explorer
dans le chat c'est parti
donc coupe explorer c'est un site qui
donne à peu près les mêmes infos que
hook maths
mais qui en plus rajoute un code couleur
donc vous avez jusqu en amont liant la
mettre l'équipe que vous voulez ici vous
rentrez l'équipe que vous souhaitez
suivre ici et vous avez ensuite du coup
les stades comme ça donc on a vu mark
bingham junior il est là on ne t'a veut
dire que on a un joueur on voit quatre
couleurs pourcentage à 2 points c'est un
des joueurs les plus efficaces le vert
et foncez donc ça veut dire qu'il est
bien meilleur que la majorité de la
ligue que la moyenne de l'est de la
ligue n 6 et première division dans ce
compartiment
on a des stats à elles sont de
différentes hurle mi distance par
rapport au match c'est souvent une
histoire de
d'actualisation donc ça faudra faudra
confirmer pourquoi ya un écart ici ça
m'intéresse je regarderai plus tard donc
le ils disent qu'il n'est pas bon à mi
distance alors que là on avait une stat
à 38% à mi distance donc on a un gros
écart faudra voir qui s'est trompé près
du panier on est oui voilà là dessus on
se rejoint par contre 81% près du panier
70% de chez eux donc voilà on a un
joueur qui est très efficace près du
cercle par rapport à la moyenne de la n6
toujours à mettre en relation en
contexte avec le fait que ça prend on
compte tous les joueurs intérieurs
extérieurs donc forcément la moyenne
près du panier elle est majorée pour un
intérieur c'est à dire que les
intérieurs sont près du cercle donc une
plus grosse réussite donc voila c'était
le plus normal pour un big d'avoir des
bonnes stats ici et pour un extérieur
d'avoir d'être dans le
moyenne ou un peu en dessous de la
moyenne et pour le trois points comme on
l'a vu très anecdotique
maintenant on va pouvoir regarder du
clip de ce joueur sauf si vous avez des
questions vous n'hésitez pas dans les
commentaires on est là pour sa marque et
bien camille junior donc je vais vous
mettre du clip de notre petit comme
d'habitude à chaque fois qu'on fait du
clip
75% c'est intéressant pour un big oui
c'est intéressant pour nous en termes de
pourcentage pour un intérieur 75% moi je
trouve que cinq jours qu'a dû toucher on
en parlait très peu parce que comme je
vous disais pouvait pas jouer à cause de
son poids ça c'est vraiment on en
parlera peut-être un jour dans une
émission envergure
l'importance de prendre de mettre du
poids sur un corps là dessus les scouts
incarne sont plus à même de vous dire si
un joueur a un morphotype qui lui permet
de prendre du poids et un mec qui peut
pas en prendre ça peut être un gros red
flag la victorine banias mas qui est
très attendu pour l'année prochaine le
français on se demande si peu prendre du
poids donc moi je n'ai pas d'infos là
dessus pour l'avoir vu jouer plusieurs
fois c'est un jour qui 13 en périphérie
au victor peut-être parce qu'il peut pas
encore ont dû jouer le contact donc si
un mec qui peut pas prendre de poids ça
peut le faire baisser de 7 en grève tout
vous avez forcément entendu parler si
vous suivez la n6 et qui est entendu
dans le top 3 de la prochaine draft
c'est la question est ce qui peut
prendre du poids evans moblie qui
actuellement joue ailier fort du côté de
2 des caves à terme si les faits pour
jouer pivot est ce qui peut prendre du
poids voilà c'est une question qu'on
peut se poser dans bing d'une gamme
juniors ça lui a mis trois ans pour
réussir à se développer musculairement
alors qu'il est dans un gros programme
avec des gros moyens qu'ils savent y
faire donc c'est toujours un facteur
décisif on va commencer chez lui par ce
qui m'intéresse le plus c'est sa défense
et sa capacité à protéger le cercle
c'est là dedans que je vais l'attendre
mark bingham juniors donc ce sera le
numéro 30
j'essaierai de toujours voulu pointer
sur l'écran pour les clips pour se les
met d'abord en vitesse classique apprend
ce qu'il met au ralenti donc là vous
allez avoir des séquences de protection
du cercle on est parti
ici je décroche
deux mondes deux mondes défenseur direct
pour venir compenser tout en coupant la
kz2 passe donc on va se mettre au
ralenti ce que j'aime bien chez lui vous
allez le voir ce qui peut bloquer avec
les deux mains il peut compter ce tacle
et demain il s'est ajusté son geste
c'est pas qu'un volleyeurs qui
utilisaient capacités athlétiques donc
là je reste connecté jusqu'au bout et
enfin je vais clause près du panier je
saute je reste verticale j'utilise ma
main droite pour contrer et derrière une
petite célébration ça fait toujours
plaisir moi j'aime bien ça me fait
toujours rire et voilà là je rêve partir
car je suis dans l'axé de passe pour ne
pas offrir un dunk par rapport au pivot
adverse qui essaie de se démarquer
derrière je saute je reste bien droit
c'est un pivot n'a vu qu'il fait pas
beaucoup de fautes il reste bien droit
donc on est face à oakland quitte une
équipe de 1000 mètres jaurès et
ses moyennes meyers est moyenne mais
qu'il a fait des bons résultats face à
de gros programme je bloque
ici et là petite célébration enfin pour
terminer bloc suivant donc on est parti
pour trois quatre buts d'affilée
donc là je le veux le pivot adverse je
souhaite dans la feinte mais jean bayle
mobilité ça qui m'intéresse c'est marcus
bingham c'est pas forcément un pivot qui
va switch and you name bien des pieds
vaut qu'ils peuvent tenir plusieurs
postes mais ça un pivot qu'à la mobilité
latéral pour depuis la partie des
lancers-francs pouvoir contester
latéralement un drive lorsque nous
ralentit donc lier au début c'est dans
la fente
mais il récupère vite les appuis je
reste verticale et encore une fois de la
main droite je vais aller contester
actions suivantes compass contre kansas
était le premier match de la saison
kansas troisième qu'une équipe côté qui
a dans ses rangs
ocz aiac badji que vous allez voir se
démarquer ici prospect très attendu que
moi j'attends fin de la loterie si vous
allez écouter le podcast
et puis vous avez en pivot alors il est
sur le terrain là david mc cormack tut
un pivot très épais donc là
on est en second rideau cette fois ci
n'y a pas vraiment de soucis à
proprement parler on est dans l'aide
défensive si j'aime bien aussi notre ami
mark bingham junior
alors oms l'armée comme ça donc c'est
game biberonne qui va se faire prendre
dans l'écran gaby brawn on parlera juste
après
la menace principale ici c'est au chalet
gbadji une petite aide qui est prise
dans l'axé si
gai biberonne comme marcus bean games
est bien placé a le temps de récupérer
son joueur lui il est toujours dans la
protection de son défenseur nous
attaquons prénom direct et va venir ici
en second rideau
balayé contre la planche
notre ami auch aurillac bâti voilà je
vous la remet une dernière fois en
vitesse réelle
et ensuite on sécurise le rebond on
revient contre oakland
et vous plaît il faut aller alors autant
il ya eu un petit un petit bug je crois
que sur les très hauts niveaux de match
de toute façon j'ai pas réussi à faire
le clip de façon plus propre que ça
cette fois ci on va tenir à l'extérieur
et on va l'accompagner jusqu'au cercle
parce qu'on a une belle mobilité latéral
pour venir le bloquer sur la planche
nadia trois blocks par match et
seulement une ville cinq fautes vous
voyez en termes de mobilité
on est plus sur les appuis c'est un
joueur qui a fait du mal sur les
changements de direction mais sur les
drives linéaire comme vous l'avez là pas
de souci pour lui j'accompagne j'ai mon
cou de
de mon bras of arms au contact
je reste verticale sur montceau
et je vais tout simplement la pine et
contre la planche ici
je vous la laisse comme ça
alors actions suivantes maintenant votre
journal défonce
contestation chose du petit bar il ya un
petit côté daniel gamme ford alors je me
suis dit quand je vais vous montrer ses
clips là vous allez penser à daniel
gaffe ordre
il ya un petit côté manon daniel gaffe
horde est une brute athlétique très très
rare c'était vraiment est assez
exceptionnel note il est beaucoup moins
verticale notre ami il est plus grands
et les plus longs mais
mais daniel gars faudrait vraiment une
piste athlétique comme on en voit
rarement c'est un joueur la marquise
bingham qui est un peu plus classique
très long qui domine au niveau n 6 et
parce que voilà grande mobile
au niveau nba maintenant il n'a pas
encore là la puissance et la verticalité
d'anelka fraude mais la confiance que tu
as la comparaison parce que j'ai pensé
assez rapidement aussi
donc voilà là en voiture de la défense
poste bas avec contestation changements
demain c'est ce que je vous avais dit
tout à l'heure c'est un joueur qui va
pouvoir utiliser demain pour contester
un tir poste bas nous vous êtes contre
yukon qui est une équipe qui était pas
mal classés dont on a déjà parlé une
fois si vous étiez là notre premier
stream en solo où j'étais en solo vont
parler d'eux tour d'anne hawkins et là
vous avez un pivot dominant adama sanogo
dont nous ferons donc parler dans les
deux trois prochaines années je pense
donc la poste bas
regardez comment ils changent de mains
plusieurs fois pour finalement prendre
la meilleure option est contesté le tir
sans faire faute
qu'a fortes sont très souvent sur les
feintes ouais moi gaffe daniel gaffe on
saute très souvent sur les feintes et
puis bah ils essaient de compenser parce
qu'il est plus petits aussi
d'anelka ford joueur que j'aime beaucoup
aussi
qui était une belle beast du côté darcos
alors on cela refait donc c'était
l'extrait précédent qui maintenant
c'était cela qui m'intéressait pardon
cela refait au ralenti donc là il
conteste la prise de position post ben
adama sanogo est très épais donc
regarder au début j'ai mon bras droit
sur son dos pour contester ma main
gauche ici sanogo c'est un joueur qui
aime bien revenir dans l'axé pour
terminer il peut finir dès demain
ça ne vaut pas son facebook je change de
mains je re change de mains hélas pour
protester le tiercé cette séquence là
qui me plaît beaucoup on essaie de le
faire image par image si je peux
donc la regarder sanogo va présenter
peut-être un bras roulé côté du coup
côté gauche
et tout de suite je reviens avec ma main
gauche pour pouvoir contrer le bras ou
la main droite
bonne défense pas de faute voilà je vous
la remet en vitesse réelle
une dernière fois et on passe le clip
suivant donc c'est un joueur qui est
très à l'aise dans le changement demain
pour protéger du poste bas
et pour pouvoir reprendre aussi les
ailiers qui partent en grève quand la
n'est pas de changements de rythme donc
ici on est là on va être sur une
séquence où j'aime beaucoup tout la
couverture de jeu donc d'abord sur le
pick and roll et ensuite sur le poste
bas et 2e pick and roll et je conteste
le dealer efficacement sans faire faute
on se la refaire parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de la france et de séquences alors
aux frises bonsoir tomax j'espère que tu
vas bien bienvenue à parmi nous on parle
comme tu le vois dans le titre de
prospects de michigan state on commence
par markus pinger junior le pivot et
ensuite on parlera de gay biberonne
l'ailier et de ma christine l'arrière
prospects 5 étoiles d'ailleurs petite
commande que je vous ai intégré point
d'exclamation clayer et vous avez
normalement voilà le récapitulatif de
tous les joueurs ne vous n'hésitez pas à
l'utiliser quand vous arrivez sur le
tchat s'ils font une commande qui vous
dit de qui on parle en art par six en
vitesse 05 donc première chose qu'on va
regarder c'est une couverture de pick
and roll is il est là on va drop et avec
un pivot très athlétique et très
puissant david mc cormack sachant que
d'autres joueurs ici harris le meneur
qui numéro 3 n'est pas une menace aux
tirs extérieurs
donc la pitié and roll
je reste en bas parce que lui va pas
tirer donc j'ai pas besoin de monter et
david mc cormack roule très rapidement
au cercle là dessus au niveau du cou
thierry portier les prêts je reste en
bas il ya une aide qui ici de notre ami
christie
tout en suivant le pivot pour ne pas me
faire prendre dans le dos vous avez vu
mccormack et demande un boulet ou pis si
c'est bien tenu je prends position poste
bas j'empêche qui prennent positif 1 que
justement mccormack soit trop près du
panier où il est très efficace donc je
conteste laiterie passe ici par la
longueur de bras tout en restant dans
son dos qu'on peut faire prendre par
derrière
là je suis poste bas le bras dans le dos
toujours avec la longueur ici pour
essayer de casser une pas ce qui peut
arriver
à cormac décide de ressortir
balles à jay jay coleman wood qui est un
shooter quasiment exclusif qui est
défendu par zhu et hauser
phrase à mother qui joue du côté de
boston qui est un ailier défensif qui
peut faire pas mal de choses mais qui
est pas très mobile il se fait prendre
dans l'écran donc lui je sais que c'est
un shooteur donc je vais pouvoir
contester un tir ici parce que c'est la
menace principale thielmann commun lundi
va pas aller au panier je le sais en
tout cas mark bingham le salage mais je
le prends pour pour le joueur est donc
je sais qu'il va y avoir un tir et je
vais les appuis sont prêts ma longueur
et je vais contester le tir ici
vous voyez c'est le genre de chose
j'espère que c'est pas trop barbon comme
séquence moi c'est ce que je préfère le
break bonne comme ça mais c'est un
joueur qui connaît son personnel sur le
terrain qui sait ce qu'il doit faire qui
sait où se placer vous avez vu premier
jour qui défendent l'extérieur ici qui
tire page tu laisses aller au cercle
mais je couvre un pivot athlétique pour
pas me faire prendre de dos je conteste
le blâme le poste base qui est la
principale demande intérieure et enfin
sur twitter là par contre je vais dans
la contestation de la tire
parce que je vais bannir l'accès au
cercle les plus grands défenseurs en
fait on peut pas arrêter totalement
attaque ou du règne des options lui
l'est c'est ce qu'il aime le moins et ça
bingham il le fait très bien je vous la
laisse maintenant en vitesse réelle et
après on avance alors en vitesse réelle
sont les pixels pardon
donc voilà ça se fait durant onze
secondes juge amy peu près 45 tonnes
pour le faire mais c'est je vais vous
montrer toute intelligence du joueur et
tout l'impact qui peut avoir
défensivement sur une équipe qui est
professionnel qui est réel chercher ici
on est chauds de la défense post bas
donc hop ou cela remets
donc voilà défense poste bas sur
quelqu'un de là c'est physiquement
développer je conteste le bras vous
voulez le hook shot et je sécurise le
rebond
actions suivantes nous qu'il est là on
va contester latéralement un drive d'un
ailier qui fluide balle en main vous
avez déjà mal ken ici et je vais prendre
l'interception on a vu dans les stats
tout à l'heure que c'est un joueur qui
fait une interception par match
notamment jean toujours deux séquences
là il va bloquer me peut aussi être
appelée steve pour le sur le ballon dans
les mains est provoquée des parts de bol
de cette manière-là donc jamal khan qui
est un ailier qui porte le ballon tu
peux partir dès demain
et sans faire faute
je viens lui arracher la balle des mains
actions suivantes je crois que
maintenant on va passer à l'attaqué
je pouvais y va exister on a vu que
c'est un genre qui efficace près du
cercle au niveau supérieur ou mal
attendent surtout jour de la finition
d'accord donc soit comme j'ai une belle
mobilité dans une turbine run ce qu'on
va voir la soie après en pick and roll
je roule au cercle et je vais finir fort
près du panier ce mot avoir aussi donc
ici en transition leva qui par devant je
me rends disponible dans laxe je suis
athlétique alors là il finit pas parce
qu'à une grosse faute mais vous voyez
que ils montrent assez haut
il ya une faute dont le dos et il va
trouver ses deux lancers francs
on a vu une fois sûr de quoi je veux
parler je trouve un lancer franc
tout simplement donc j'ai pas voulu
mettre au ralenti parce que c'est dur in
one classic
up
donc ça va planter votre problème
vous me dites il est toujours avec moi
oui c'est bon
alors donc ça c'est ce qu'on vient de
voir ici
bon bah je vous la laisse comme ça tu as
tu parles c'est pas grave ça tourne rim
orange dunk faute
l'action suivante
donc là je ressors la base et on voit là
on va exister maintenant là dessus tout
simplement sur deux les finitions près
du panier au lait ou peu
au ralenti dont vous voyez que lille
bonne défense qui vient le prendre à
deux je ressors tout de suite sur mon
porteur de balle qui est ouvert il
m'indique disponible en haut donc dans
la zone et je vais finir à une main au
dessus du panier en efficacité en
brutalité actions suivantes on se la met
en vitesse réelle pareil vous allez le
voir au dunk ici je me rends disponible
et je finis qu'est ce qu'ils voient ils
voient qu'on est une défense de zone la
défense va venir se concentrer ce
collapse et au niveau du porteur de
balle donc lui il va aller dans le déni
kin spot et finir au dunk
sans défense possible donc ici vous avez
un drive qui est contestée de là donc
c'est notre ami max festi
hop je me rends disponible et finalement
au dessus du panier alors il peut finir
à 2 mois c'est juste qu'il aime bien
mettre un peu plus de un peu plus de sel
et finir à une main mais il peut très
bien finir à demain dans les deux cas
c'est possible ici je me mets dans le
dunk in spot et je finis donc encore une
action
à haut pourcentage ce que j'aime la ces
qui se repositionne alors ça passe tant
m ici
donc vous voyez il est là il avait
essayé de prendre position poste de ben
arfa prend pas alico hall qui drive au
panier pas un grand porteur de balle
la défense qui sont centres ici et donc
intelligemment je me replace dans la
queen pas facile et je finis près du
panier hop punk sans aucune difficulté
c'est là dessus qu'on va beaucoup à
attendre notre ami
mark bingham junior sur un niveau
supérieur en nba c'est un joueur qui est
aussi capable de finir poste bas c'est
une chose qu'on retrouve
particulièrement nba si jamais parce que
nous on va en parler après il n'a pas
l'occasion il n'a pas la chance de se
retrouver à l'étagé nba qui doit passer
pas de la g-league ou par un championnat
européen a peut-être plus lui a demandé
de pouvoir finir poste bas donc c'est un
joueur qui allait sur du bras ou les
vous allez le voir
rouler main droite parce que je suis
très très long sur un pivot défensif
assez intéressant
ici
on va peut-être le voir un peu plus en
difficulté
en fait comme je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est un pivot qui a pris y en a
qui a pris du poids mais il est à 104 kg
pour deux maîtresses il était encore ya
pas si longtemps 92 kg donc très très
faim il a encore du mal sur les pipots
très développé en attaque pour pouvoir
dominer nos campagnes billet s'il arrive
que des groupes bestiaux on n'attendra
pas pour faire ça y arrivera pas en fait
ils n'arrivent pas forcément enfoncé
pour le dessus sur son joueur et la
finir nous voyez comme il essaie de
prendre position et finit par reculer
comparé près du panier et on finit par
reculer reculer et à marcher voilà donc
où l'attendait pas là dessus de plus en
plus piquionne pop catch and shoot
mi-distance alors on a vu les
prestations pas encore exceptionnel le
volume est pas très grand
mais c'est en développement tout
simplement pouvoir sur une défense qui
concentre à l'intérieur comme le fait
penn state ici à capable de me rendre
disponible pour du mi distance
et en fluidité pouvoir punir derrière
voilà c'est quelque chose qu'on n'avait
pas les années précédentes où tout cas
très peu et que cette année on retrouve
un peu plus tard on parlait de daniel
gars faudrait c'est quelque chose que
d'anelka ford travaille aussi de son
côté que qu'on attend pour pouvoir
passer en riant step être capable
aujourd'hui on a une bille est tout
simplement un niveau professionnel de
finir
un jour du pick and pop ici on est en
transition la défense monte pas sur lui
il prend à trois points on a vu
l'entente peu moins d'un par match
j'aime bien le fait qu'ils n'hésitent
pas beaucoup
l'armée c'est de la transition
l'eurostar mais fluide parce que les
pixels c'est pas beau
la défense allemande pas je le prends je
le tente
la gestuelle est plutôt fluide donc il
ya quelque chose à travailler de ce côté
là aussi moi je serais pas surpris si
d'ici 4-5 ans
ce soit un joueur qui puisse tourner à
33 34% sur ces situations là ce qui
serait vraiment une arme supplémentaire
pour lui là on va être en est revenu
face à kansas david mc cormack mubadala
ses mensurations qui est une grosse bête
en ici post post 5 ans battures du
fesfop capables de prendre de vitesse un
dribble quelque chose qui peut faire
voilà vous voyez bon démarrage mon
premier pas prime à gauche et je finis
ma droite
en utilisant le panier pour protéger du
bloc
ici donc bon premier pas main gauche je
finis ma droite et j'utilise le panier
pour protéger ce en plus demandé de le
faire aussi
là c'est un joueur qui est un passeur
fonctionnel c'est un joueur qui est un
passeur intelligent je vois que je suis
pris à deux je ressors tout de suite
pour mon porteur de balle à leur égard
des pénos aux tirs à trois points il
décale râches macasty qui lui est un
meilleur shooter mais voilà avant
l'intelligence de tout de suite pouvoir
ressortir le ballon je suis pris à deux
je ressors tout de suite la balle il ya
une faille dans la défense et création
ouvert
autre situation
on va le voir passer cette fois ci de
clélia trois points
ici je vois le cut et je peux
transmettre directement c'est un passeur
qu'on appelle fonctionnel c'est le genre
de joueur qui a quand il ya une faille
va la trouver donc on a vu moins d'une
passes décisives par match mais la balle
elle reste pas bloqué
mécanique ça réagit bien donc c'est
quelque chose qui me fait acheter un peu
plus le joueur qu'un simple intérieur
brut al assad joueur intelligent
en vitesse réelle je vois de jouer aux
orres qui coupent et je transmet
directement
ici alors ici c'est une de mes actions
préférées dans tout le basket quand on
est un intérieur
en nba vous avez daniel taille ce qu'il
le fait est excellemment bien tu l'avais
d'autres exemples où le dit en me mois
d'années tesla qui me vient en tête al
horford aussi qui me vient en tête c'est
quelque chose qu'on avait beaucoup chez
les celtics c'est ne pas mettre un écran
mais comme aime mettre un écran je
m'explique ici vous avez un drive de
hautcoeur delà vous avez le rim
protecteur le pivot adverse qui est là
il voit que sont pourtant de bâle va
aller au cirque je vais mettre mon corps
en opposition avec une sorte d'écran
écrans mobiles les sens positif semble
prendre la position de l'écran pour pas
me faire siffler écrans mobiles et je
vais empêcher l'aide de la part de mon
intérieur enfin de l'intérieur adverse
vous voyez tout simplement je mets mon
corps
histoire de je veux bouger en même temps
notre petit écran mobile mais tu n'es
jamais sifflé c'est un geste légal et
qui permet d'avoir un deux points
faciles en vitesse réelle vous voyez va
très vite on voit qu à zaria et ça
permet de voir deux points donc encore
une fois un jour si on prend les règles
qui comprend la géométrie d'un terrain
et qui peut vous permettre de trouver
en fait une faille une fluidité
collective sans grande difficulté
actions suivantes pick and roll veut
alors ça c'est quelque chose qui me
gonfle chez la plupart des intérieurs
actuellement une sieste et qui savent
peu mais de poser des écrans mark
bingham ne fait pas l'exception des fois
ya des bons écrans mais trop souvent
d'azur d'écran soft là qui est posée
mécaniquement parce que le système dit
de le faire mais qui ne craint
absolument aucun décalage vous allez
pouvoir le voir ici en guinée sera
l'hôte si vous voyez que la prise et les
pas bien posée où n'existe pas bien
l'écart de ses jambes entièrement
et qu'on va avoir un soft roll
sans aucun intérêt donc voilà je viens
poser un écran vous allez voir c'est 7
pouces là parce qu'il faut poser un
écran mais je voudrais même pas en
contact avec le porteur de balle adverse
gpat décalage et s'affine attaque
stérile on peut se permettre ici aux
maux du contact
regardez
je pose l'écran le porte le défenseur
adverse n'a même pas à essayer de
l'éviter
il n'est jamais gêné par un piquet
junior
et la défense peut totalement avec en
plus mccormack est un pivot mobile est
d'être l ombre à la défense peut
totalement
contester l'action sans aucune
difficulté
voilà
alors restée jours qu'est ce qu'on a ah
bon on arrive on a fini on est revenu
sur le bloc de base donc voilà je vais
vous laisser tourner pendant que l'on
parle fait un petit bilan donc c'est un
pivot
classique assez mobile qui a mis du
temps à se développer parce qu'il ya un
problème de prise de poids qu'il l'a
vraiment handicapé sur les terrains
maintenant ça c'est réglé c'est pour ça
que ses stats ont doublé et qu'on en
parle un peu plus c'est un pivot qui va
finir en attaque efficacement qui
trouvent des fautes qui assez athlétique
et qui a pas beaucoup une panoplie
offensive très développée à on n'a pas
beaucoup de mouvements mais on a un
premier pas quand même assez intéressant
un peu touchées à développer au fur et à
mesure c'est un joueur que vous n'allez
pas payer très cher nous vous allez la
voir au second tour facilement voir un
draft il ya des fortes chances que ce
joueur là en fait comme un rat de la
compétitivité pour les poste de pivot
second tour avec notamment mccormack et
d'autres consitera au fur et à mesure il
ya moyen que vous l'ayez drafted qu'il
fasse une summer league qui ils
séduisent ou non une franchise nba qui
extrait nantes j league est peut-être en
europe où il ferait le bonheur de
beaucoup d équipes parce que c'est un
très bon protecteur de paniers et c'est
un très beau coéquipiers donc voilà sur
sur un petit temps du jour dix quinze
minutes je pense que c'est un pivot qui
peut vraiment avoir une valeur positive
pour une équipe compétitive vous me
dites ce que vous pensez de ce joueur et
puis on va tranquillement passer au
second je vais en profiter en même temps
pour faire un petit un petit tweet pour
dire qu'il connaît toujours en live
pendant que ça tourne hop je vous
redonne si jamais ça vous intéresse
le lien de notre site hamburger ou vous
avez toutes les infos jour ce qui tombe
actuellement et autres liens twitter
avec le twitter envergure et mon twitter
perso si ça vous intéresse j'ai repris
un peu les threads et c'est là que
j'essaie de ne pas être qu'un relais à
un tweet envergure parce que c'est
maintenant c'est envergure qui me pour
lequel je me consacre à 100 quasiment
100% mais mais voilà si ça vous
intéresse je poste aussi des choses sur
les jours n 6 et et j'insulte un peu les
arbitres quand mais vous joue mais
toujours avec beaucoup d'humour
évidemment
un plus petit tweet toujours en live
et on va partir choqué du bois
voilà les seniors michigan state
et le lien du live
on est parti
donc game one
on va aller sur le profil un petit peu
statistiques on va essayer de regarder
sur
sur envergure si ça fonctionne
et je me remets le chat sous les yeux
il alors est ce que ça fonctionne mais
le citoyen point galère encore sa part
annoncé ma connexion au fait qu en
colère alors d'ailleurs vous voyez big
board 2021 vous avez vu le tweet qui est
passé
demain soir 20h on a une émission où la
team envergure dévoile son
son big board donc demain soir 20 heures
vous aurez nos geeks board en live sur
youtube avec nous globalement le top 10
le top 15 il y aura alan alan riou qui
sera là il y aura alexandre ce sera
animée par pierre pierre migaud
et je serai là aussi peut-être y aura
d'autres copains je vous avoue j'ai pas
forcément pu suivre toute l'actualité
dans le groupe envergure mais non il
n'ya pas les stocks non plus pas grave
mais voilà ne ratez pas le rendez vous
de demain soir avec du coup nos board
dévoilé on sait pas on sait pas ce pôle
est entre nous donc les moyens coup on
est des petites surprises mais j'ai
prévu des des joueurs
qui je pense ne figureront pas encore
dans les bords de tes copains je sais
mon côté visiteurs on sera on verra ça
ensemble demain donc demain à 20 heures
que sera ce soir sur la chaîne youtube
essaiera de vous mettre le lien
vous mettre le lien dans le dans le chat
est vrai que je fasse que je passe la
commande du tube ce serait pas mal donc
gaby bonne alors il est pointé ici à 2 m
01 c'est un format donc à un poste 3 4
95 qu'il obtient aussi grandi dans le
michigan c'est pour ça qu'ils jouent à
michigan state entre autres il est resté
dans le coin il était dans le top 100 de
la plupart des
observateurs dont le spn il joue à mi
chemin de cette forcément comme tous les
prospects de ce soir vous avez les
stades sous les yeux la 13 points 4,7
rebonds une passe